Ist die Kollision schon gegeben, wenn wir einen
Rap-Text haben, wo jemand sagt: "Ich
ficke die Schlampe tot, sie liegt
bereits im Wachkoma." Und ich glaube, genau
das ist der Punkt. Was ist Kunst und wo endet
die Toleranz, was die Kollision
-der Grundrechte anbetrifft?
-Herzlich Willkommen zu 13 Fragen. Wir
diskutieren mit KünstlerInnen und Kulturschaffenden
über Kunstfreiheit
und starten direkt mit der ersten
Frage von 13 Fragen, mit unserer Konfliktfrage:
Müssen wir Kunst von den Kunstschaffenden
trennen? Wenn ihr sagt: Ja, Kunstwerk
und die Person, die das erschaffen
hat, müssen unbedingt getrennt werden,
dann geht ihr auf das grüne Feld. Und wenn ihr sagt:
Nee, nicht trennen, dann geht
ihr auf das gelbe Feld. Okay,
eure Positionen sind klar, kommen
wir zum Thema: Michael Jackson,
Woody Allen, Roman Polanski – die Liste geht
noch viel länger. Es geht um Kunstschaffende,
denen sexualisierte
Gewalt, Machtmissbrauch oder andere
Verbrechen vorgeworfen werden. Wie geht
ihr dann als Fans damit um? Hört
ihr die Musik trotzdem weiter? Schaut
ihr die Filme noch? Lasst ihr die Bilder
hängen? Oder sagt ihr: Nee, da vergeht mir
ehrlich gesagt der Spaß an deren Kunst.
Es ist und bleibt ein moralisches Dilemma,
aber wie können wir eigentlich die Kunst
schützen, wenn der oder die Künstlerin
sich strafbar macht? Geht das überhaupt?
Bei 13 Fragen sind sich meine Gäste
wie üblich erst mal uneinig.
Umso spannender: Werden sie am Ende
dieser Folge doch noch einen
Kompromiss finden oder vielleicht sogar eine Lösung?
Wir werden sehen. Aber jetzt erst mal
an euch: Auf welcher Seite des Feldes würdet
ihr denn stehen? Grün oder gelb?
Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare. Für euch
liebe Gäste heißt es ab jetzt: Wenn ihr der anderen
Seite des Spielfeldes in einem
Argument zustimmen wollt oder einfach
Bock habt, einen Schritt auf die zuzugehen,
weil ihr euch denkt: Ja, da sage ich mit,
dann könnt ihr einen Schritt einfach
nach vorne laufen. Wenn ihr sagt: Nein
und das vielleicht auch mitten, während jemand
redet zum Ausdruck bringen wollt,
dann könnt ihr das machen, während die Person
spricht. Ihr könnt das gerne
organisch in eure Bewegungen einfliessen lassen.
Für mich ist natürlich das Ziel, so
viele von euch wie möglich hier am Ende
im Kompromissfeld zu sehen. Mal gucken,
ob ich das schaffe. Peter, ich möchte gern
bei dir anfangen. Mit einer leichten
Frage zum Einstieg: Kannst du noch Michael
-Jackson hören?
-Ich kann noch Michael Jackson hören. Ich
finde es nicht gut, was er wahrscheinlich,
ganz sicher ist es ja immer noch nicht,
getan haben könnte oder sollte. Aber
ich glaube, es ist unmöglich, morgens im Bad
zu stehen, einen Song wie "Thriller"
oder "Beat it" zu hören und dann zu sagen: Nee,
nee, ich kann das jetzt nicht gut
finden, weil der hat schlechte Dinge gemacht
und deswegen ist der Song auch schlecht.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Dann geißelt man sich selber und kommt
in innere Zwänge und Konflikte.
KünstlerIn und Kunstwerk sollten
also deiner Meinung nach getrennt werden?
In den allermeisten Fällen, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist Unsinn, das Werk
und die Künstler zu verketten. Man muss
das trennen, weil manche Kunstwerke werden
einfach sehr viel größer oder gehören
auch dem Publikum und das Publikum macht
etwas daraus. Und deswegen finde
ich, man sollte das unbedingt trennen.
Balbina, was sagst du dazu, wenn du
morgens im Bad Radio an hast und es läuft
Michael Jackson. Geht es dir
dann genauso wie Peter?
Ich würde sagen, es ist schwierig
für mich, Michael Jackson mittlerweile
zu hören und ich persönlich erinnere
mich dann jedes Mal, wenn ich seine Stimme
einfach höre, obwohl ich weiß,
dass an Michael Jackson Songs so viel mehr
Menschen auch beteiligt waren. Er hat
ja nicht den kompletten Kosmos alleine
erschaffen. Dennoch ist seine Stimme
die Stimme von der Person,
mit der ich diese Vorwürfe
identifiziere. Ich finde, es ist schwierig,
das Kunstobjekt vom Künstler zu trennen.
Einfach deshalb, weil der Künstler,
der es erschaffen hat, hat es erschaffen
mit allen Erfahrungen, mit all dem,
was er ist und mit dem allen, was er gesehen
hat und daraus extrahiert.
Und deswegen kann ich es mir persönlich
nicht vorstellen, das zu trennen. Ich weiß
-nicht, wie das gehen soll.
-Warum sollten wir denn deiner Meinung nach
-Kunst und Kunstschaffende nicht trennen?
-Ich denke, die Kunst, die man als
Kunstschaffender erstellt – sei es ich als Musikerin
oder Schriftsteller,
bildende Künstler – diese Kunst kommt
aus uns heraus als Individuum mit allem,
was uns charakterlich ausmacht, auch mit allen
Erfahrungen, die wir gesammelt
haben, mit unserer Wahrnehmungsbrille
und natürlich auch mit all dem, was wir getan
haben und was wir sind. Und es ist
deswegen zwangsläufig für mich,
dass das Kunstwerk, was wir produzieren,
in einer gewissen Weise durch
eine Nabelschnur mit uns verbunden
bleibt. Würde man jetzt die relativ schlechte
Kunst von Adolf Hitler betrachten,
Ja, das ist jetzt ein ganz krasses Beispiel
und plötzlich sagen: Ja, das sind
aber ganz schöne Bilder, die der Adolf
da gemalt hat, wäre es für uns ganz
klar, in der Gesellschaft zu sagen: Ja, aber
die wurden von Adolf Hitler
gemalt und deswegen kann man sie eben nicht
aus dem Zusammenhang ziehen und sagen:
das hat mit Adolf Hitler gar nichts zu tun.
Ersan, würdest du ihr denn da zustimmen,
Balbina, mit den Kunstwerken von Adolf
-Hitler?
-Also erstmal ist Adolf Hitler kein
Künstler, sondern ein Tyrann und ein Faschist
oder was auch immer. Aber er ist
kein Künstler und hat auch keine
Kunstwerke gemacht. Er hat vielleicht
gemalt, was man vielleicht als Kunst
verklären kann. Und ich finde
den Vergleich von Michael Jackson,
der unter Umständen Kinder missbraucht haben
könnte, mit Adolf Hitler, der Bilder
gemalt hat, schwierig – also
auf der Strecke bleiben dabei einfach
ganz viele Etappen. Und deswegen ist für mich
der Vergleich nicht gültig. Wenn es darum geht,
ob man KünstlerInnen und Kunstwerk
trennen muss, würde ich sagen: Ne, da gehe
ich nicht mit. Also wenn wir keine Kunst
mehr betrachten dürfen,
die von KünstlerInnen entstammt,
die etwas Falsches getan haben oder eine Straftat
begangen haben, dann wäre,
und das ist sicherlich eines
der größten oder häufigsten Argumente
oder Totschlagargumente, dann
wären die Museen wahrscheinlich fast leer
und auch die Kinos leer, weil ich kenne
viele KünstlerInnen, die sicherlich
je nach Straftatbeständen
Straftaten begehen, sei es Drogenmissbrauch, sei
es irgendwie andere Dinge. Man muss
die Dinge einfach in dem, was sie sind,
belassen und vielleicht auch die Tat
der KünstlerIn mit einbeziehen
-in die Betrachtung des Kunstwerkes.
-Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt gleich
widersprechen. Das ist ja eben die Definition:
Was ist Kunst? Und wer ist
ein Künstler? Und diese Definition,
die endet irgendwo und fängt irgendwo
an und genau deswegen bringe ich dieses krasse
Beispiel. Adolf Hitler ist
ein eindeutiges Beispiel. Und deswegen habe
ich auch gesagt: Diese Kunst wird nie
als Kunst gelten. Dennoch: danach
kommen ganz viele andere Stufen. Und ab wann ist
denn die Stufe erreicht, wo du sagst:
Das ist ein Künstler. Und das ist Kunst?
Dann lasst uns doch direkt mal bei der Definition
von Kunst und von der Aufgabe
von KünstlerInnen bleiben. Elke,
du bist Herausgeberin eines der größten
Kunstmagazine Deutschlands. Was würdest
du denn sagen: Welche Aufgabe hat
-ein Künstler, hat eine Künstlerin?
-Oh Gott, was ist das für eine Riesenfrage?
Kunstschaffende und ihre Werke
sind zunächst einmal etwas ganz
Unterschiedliches und trotzdem
haben sie natürlich viel miteinander zu tun.
Ich würde sagen, ein Werk ist immer
mehr als sein Autor oder seine Autorin.
Man merkt das vor allen Dingen,
wenn man die Kunstgeschichte betrachtet.
Interessiert es uns noch, dass Caravaggio
jemanden umgebracht hat? Oder wollen
wir jetzt einfach nur seine tollen
Gemälde sehen? Ich glaube, dass vor allen Dingen
im Laufe der Zeit irgendwann
das Werk übrig bleibt und der Autor
oder die Autorin, der Künstler oder die Künstlerin
immer unwichtiger wird.
Ein großer Teil der Kunst beschäftigt
sich mit der Frage, was eigentlich Kunst ist.
Also diese Selbstreflexivität ist
ja ausschlaggebend für die Kunst. Etwas,
was Adolf Hitlers Kunst bestimmt
nicht hatte. Insofern kann man das leicht
aussortieren. Balbina hat natürlich
völlig recht, wenn sie sagt: Es gibt Fälle,
die sind klar und es gibt Fälle, die sind
grenzwertig, aber deswegen debattieren
wir ja darüber. Das heißt, für mich hat
Kunst eine gewisse Komplexität. Also Kunst
hat eben eine Offenheit und deswegen müssen
wir überhaupt darüber diskutieren,
wem sie gehört. Weil für mich ist
Kunst eben das Werk, das sein Autor,
seine Autorin überstrahlt, überragt.
Also ein Werk, das komplexer ist als das,
was der Künstler oder die Künstlerin
reingesteckt hat. Deswegen finde
ich auch das mit der Nabelschnur, das ist
vielleicht die Sicht der Künstlerin.
Aber eigentlich gibt es auch eine Nabelschnur
zum Rezipienten,
zur Rezipientin. Und die ist
vielleicht genauso wichtig und insofern gehört
das Kunstwerk eben auch nicht nur dem,
der es erschaffen hat, sondern das Kunstwerk
ist dann ein Kunstwerk, wenn es eine Komplexität
von seinem eigenen Recht hat.
Und, wenn wir da andere Sachen drin
sehen können, als vielleicht die Generationen
vor uns als vielleicht ein anderer
Mensch und als vielleicht auch der Mensch,
-der es gemacht hat.
-Anna, du bist selbst Künstlerin. Würdest
-du Elke da zustimmen?
-In Teilen. Also dass es sehr komplex ist
und dass auch ein Kunstwerk eine eigene
Komplexität braucht, da würde ich dir
auf jeden Fall zustimmen. Das Thema
liegt mir am Herzen, weil ich selbst bildende
Künstlerin bin und immer wieder merke,
je mehr mediale Aufmerksamkeit ich bekomme,
desto mehr trage ich auch eine Verantwortung
für mein Publikum
und auch für jüngere
Generationen. Außerdem habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es in letzter Zeit
vermehrt vorgekommen ist, dass Fälle
von Machtmissbrauch in der Medienlandschaft
vorgekommen sind.
Und zwar so oft, dass man das einfach
nicht mehr ignorieren kann.
Ich glaube, wir merken schon zu Beginn
dieser Diskussion: Es ist sehr komplex.
Peter, der Philosoph Roland Barthes,
der hat 1967 geschrieben "Der Tod des Autors".
Und in diesem Text schrieb er darüber,
dass der Text immer losgelöst von Autor
oder Autorin betrachtet werden sollte.
Und seiner Meinung nach erschafft die lesende
Person den Text und nicht der Verfasser
oder die Verfasserin. Würdest du ihm
-da zustimmen?
-Nicht ganz. Das ist eine Sichtweise, aber
wo schon ein bisschen Wahrheit drin
liegt, ist, dass der Künstler es irgendwann
loslässt. Also ich meine das auch schon
von einigen Künstlern gehört zu haben,
die gesagt haben: Wenn das Kunstwerk
fertig ist oder der Song vielleicht,
dann entlasse ich das in die Welt und dann
gehört es nicht mehr mir. Das ist so
ein bisschen wie in der Entbindung.
Also diese Nabelschnur, von der eben schon
geredet wurde, wird dann gekappt und das werden
die White Stripes wahrscheinlich
bestätigen können, die noch nie eine Fußballstadionshymne
schreiben wollten,
wo das Publikum gesagt
hat: Wir machen das jetzt dazu.
Und dieses Nabelschnur-Beispiel, das bringt
auch, finde ich einen ganz schönen
Vergleich rein, der mir immer ein bisschen
hilft, bei meiner noch sehr harten
Position zu bleiben. Ich betrachte
die Künstler als Eltern und die Kunstwerke
als Kinder. Und klar steckt ganz,
ganz viel von den Eltern in den Kindern.
Die haben sich da zusammengetan, was erschaffen,
was ihnen schon recht ähnlich
ist. Aber man würde nie auf die Idee
kommen zu sagen: Du bist dessen Sohn.
Naja, in manchen Fällen schon, aber man
sollte nicht auf die Idee kommen zu sagen:
Deine Eltern waren mies und deswegen geben
wir dir erst recht keine Chance,
deswegen wirst du sofort
gecancelt, sondern man muss sagen, das hat sich
irgendwann voneinander gelöst und wir geben
dem eine Chance. So ein bisschen
-sehe ich es auch bei Werk und Künstler.
-Werke mit Nazi-Hintergrund. Menschen mit
-Nazi-Hintergrund gibt es doch heute auch.
-Na ja, also ich bin jetzt nicht im
Bildwerk von Adolf Hitler, da bin
ich jetzt gar nicht so firm, aber ich würde
auch sagen: Meine Güte, wenn es ein schönes
Bild ist, ein schönes Bild.
Was meint ihr? KünstlerInnen
vermitteln uns durch Ihre Kunstwerke ja
auch Botschaften. Haben Sie dadurch
eine besondere moralische Verantwortung?
Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare. An die gelbe
Seite: Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne
positionieren, Balbina, du hast dich
schon positioniert zu dem, was Peter gerade
gesagt hat. Du bist ein klein
bisschen, ein Müh auf ihn zugegangen. Warum?
Ich bin einen kleinen Schritt auf ihn
zugegangen, weil dieses Argument,
das er gebracht hat, richtig
ist. Natürlich ist ein Kunstwerk
in dem Augenblick, wo es in die Welt
hinaustritt, wird es betrachtet.
Und natürlich ist es in der Dimension
des Betrachters etwas anderes
als in der Dimension des
Erschaffenden. Und dem würde ich nie widersprechen.
Und deswegen gehe ich auch ein bisschen
vor, weil ich eben genau finde,
das Problem liegt in dieser Grauzone.
Erstens: Was ist wirklich,
auf welchen Kunstbegriff können wir uns
einigen? Darüber haben wir ja gerade einen
Diskurs gehabt. Ich glaube, das ist
auch nicht allen klar. Was ist Kunst
und was ist keine Kunst? Und das ist
genau der Punkt, warum ich hier auf dieser Seite
stehe. Weil ich finde,
Kunstfreiheit allgemein Freiheit begrenzt sich immer
dort, wo diese Freiheit anderen
Menschen schadet. Und ich finde alles,
was gegen Grundrechte verstößt,
gegen Eingriffe Richtung Menschenwürde,
also überall, alles, was mit den Grundrechten
kollidiert, muss dann nochmal
hinterfragt werden. Und genau das ist
der Punkt, der es so schwierig macht zu sagen,
wo es diese Kollisionen gegeben. Ist
die Kollision gegeben in dem Augenblick,
wo ich eine Installation mache und jemand
mit der Pumpgun irgendwie erschieße,
ist da die Kollision gegeben? Oder ist
die Kollision schon gegeben, wenn wir einen
Rap- Text haben, wo jemand sagt: Ich ficke
die Schlampe tot. Sie liegt bereits
im Wachkoma. Und ich glaube genau das ist
der Punkt. Was ist Kunst und wo endet
die Toleranz, was die Kollision
der Grundrechte anbetrifft.
Aber jetzt hast du ein neues
Thema eigentlich aufgemacht. Wir müssen
unterscheiden. Also bei Michael
Jackson zum Beispiel, da geht es um die Frage:
Was hat der Mann gemacht? Und das findet
sich ja nicht in seinem Werk. Und jetzt
hast du aber über Werke gesprochen,
die wiederum Rechte verletzen und moralische,
also das finde ich, das sind zwei
unterschiedliche Dinge. Man muss die Fälle
auseinanderhalten, wo es nur darum geht:
Gefällt uns jetzt die ethische Einstellung
des Künstlers nicht? Oder finden wir das im Werk?
Gefällt uns die ethische Aussage
oder gefallen uns diese krassen
Sachen, die in dem Text vorkommen, gefällt uns
das nicht? Ich finde, das sind zwei
unterschiedliche Fälle und da muss man
sehr unterschiedlich
auch über Kunstfreiheit reden.
Peter, du bist beim Stichwort
Menschenrechte, beim Stichwort Grundrechte
einen Schritt auf Balbina
zugegangen. Magst du nochmal erklären, warum?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist die Baseline,
auf die man sich einigen kann. Also man kann
sagen, wenn ein Kunstwerk ganz
offensichtlich gegen die Verfassung
verstößt, dann muss man nicht mehr
groß über den Kunstbegriff reden. Zum Beispiel
wenn jemand singt: bitte
geht, vergewaltigt – kannst du sofort
-auf den Index stecken.
-Aber was ist, wenn Georg Baselitz sagt:
Frauen können nicht malen. Das ist
eindeutig nicht verfassungswidrig. Aber
-es geht mir krass auf die Nerven!
-Ja klar, dann kannst du sagen: Georg
Baselitz ist echt ein totaler Trottel.
Und dann kannst du aber immer noch überlegen,
findest du seine Werke jetzt
interessant oder nicht interessant? Ich finde sowohl,
dass er Quatsch erzählt als auch seine Werke
nicht besonders interessant.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob sich das eine automatisch
aus dem anderen ergibt.
-Vielleicht ist es auch Zufall.
-Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht. Aber jetzt
frage ich mich das jedes Mal, wenn ich seine Arbeit
sehe. Ich fand die immer
-als Studentin eigentlich total gut, aber –
-Aber jetzt hat er es dir versaut.
Das ist aber auch okay. Ich glaube, es ist
vollkommen okay, dass man für sich selber
sagt, also wie du eben gesagt
hast: Ich bin bei dem Thema Pädophilie,
Kindesmissbrauch, bin ich total
sensibel und deswegen habe ich kein Bock,
Michael Jackson zu hören. Finde ich total
okay. Ich finde es auch total okay,
wenn jemand sagt, ich habe einen Club,
ich engagiere mich bei dem Thema, ich mag
den nicht wegen dieser Sachen. Bei mir
läuft kein Michael Jackson – finde
ich okay. Man sollte nur nicht sagen:
Ihr dürft jetzt alle Michael Jackson nicht
mehr hören. Also daraus ein Gesetz
machen, das finde ich dann zu viel.
Muss ich schon wieder zustimmen. Ja,
also die Frage, wie wir mit KünstlerInnen
umgehen, die sich beispielsweise
strafbar gemacht haben oder die anderweitig
aufgefallen sind, negativ, das ist ja
eine große Spannweite. Die ist deswegen wichtig
und auch für mich wichtig, weil ich das Gefühl
habe, dass wir darüber noch nicht
so richtig sprechen können. Also
die Fronten verhärten sich immer sehr,
sehr schnell, wenn es um so etwas geht.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben noch
keinen Weg gefunden, darüber sinnvoll
konstruktiv zu sprechen. Ich bin gespannt,
-ob wir heute einen Schritt weiterkommen.
-Ersan, du bist Regisseur. Stellen wir uns
mal Folgendes vor: Du inszeniert ein Stück
am Theater. Das läuft schon über einige
Wochen. Das läuft gut, meinetwegen
jeden Abend. Auf einmal passiert ein Skandal.
Einer der Schauspieler dieses Theaterstücks,
der hat sich strafbar
gemacht. Was tust du?
Heute Abend ist die nächste Show.
Also ich würde mir erstmal die Frage
stellen, was denn die Straftat ist.
Ich kann jetzt nicht über einen
Drogendelikt und eine Vergewaltigung
sagen, das ist gleichwertig.
Also wahrscheinlich würde ich bei einem
Drogendelikte sagen, der soll
bitte spielen. Wenn ich hören würde,
dass er eine Kollegin vergewaltigt hat
oder irgendjemand anderes, würde ich schon
die Frage stellen, ob man überhaupt
eine Integrität hat, auf eine Bühne zu gehen
und auch etwas mit dem Werk erzählt.
Und dadurch, dass man ja etwas begangen hat,
was auch dem Werk widerspricht, ob man
es dann noch vertreten kann. Und im Gegensatz
zur Malerei ist Thaeter, glaube ich,
ja doch etwas, was in dem Moment halt immer
wieder stattfindet. Und dadurch ist
ja auch der Schauspieler in dem Moment
Vertreter des Kunstwerkes und wird
auch gewissermaßen selber zum Kunstwerk
und würde ja dem selber
widersprechen, weil du kannst auf keiner Bühne
in Deutschland allen Ernstes so etwas wie eine Vergewaltigung
vertreten. Da würde
ich durchaus sagen, dass die Person
heute Abend nicht spielen kann.
Der Schauspieler wird also zum Teil
des Kunstwerks. Balbina, du bist da einen
-Schritt auf Ersan zugegangen.
-Ja, ich finde, er hat einen wichtigen
Punkt genannt, und zwar den Punkt
Drogendelikt vs. sexuelle Gewalt.
Genau das ist ja die Crux zu bestimmen:
Was ist denn schlimm? Was ist
die Definition von schlimm? Und ich denke,
wir kommen dem einen Schritt näher,
wenn wir das so betrachten, dass jedes
Mal dann, wenn der Gemeinschaft geschadet wird
oder einem Individuum, also
wirklich Gewalt zugefügt wird, gibt es einfach
keine wirkliche Kunstfreiheit
mehr. Aber wie du gesagt hast, bei einem
Drogendelikten, also, da finde ich jetzt
nicht, dass man jetzt den kompletten
Künstler ausklammern muss. Und für mich
ist zum Beispiel der Besitz von Marihuana
keine Straftat und auch nicht der Handel.
Dennoch ist das geltendes Gesetz.
Ich glaube, das, was legal ist und was strafbar
ist, ist vielleicht nicht
das geeignete Maß. Aber ich glaube,
wenn wir jetzt von einer klaren
Menschenrechtsverletzung
ausgehen, dazu gehört eine Vergewaltigung,
gehören Sexualdelikte etc. Das ist
universell etwas, das man als falsch abtun
kann. Wenn du jetzt im Iran lebst und dort
mit einem Menschen irgendwo geknutscht
hast, weil du homosexuell bist. Das ist
dann auch eine Straftat. Insofern ist
nicht jede Straftat gleich Straftat,
also in welchem Kontext ist das eine Straftat?
Aber ich glaube, da sind
wir uns weitestgehend einig.
Seid ihr euch da einig, weil dann
könnt ihr euch gerne dazu positionieren.
Einmal an die gelbe Seite:
Menschenrechtsverletzungen als eindeutige
Grenze ist das was, wo ihr euch
einig seid mit Ersan?
Also sofern du das Grundgesetz als Basis
siehst. Verstöße gegen das Grundgesetz.
Ich sehe das als Basis –
Verstöße gegen das Grundgesetz.
Ich glaube aber, das Beispiel
war eben so ein bisschen verwirrend,
weil wenn der Schauspieler das am Tag
erfährt, dann ist er ja erst mal Teil
einer laufenden Ermittlung und dann
muss man ihn erst mal rausziehen und dann
wartet er praktisch. Man weiß
nicht, stimmt das? Ist das nur ein Verdacht?
Und dann wartet man, bis sich das Gesetz
drum kümmert. Dann wird er verurteilt
und dann kriegt er eine gesetzliche
Strafe. Und wenn die abgelaufen ist,
hat er meiner Meinung nach das Recht,
alles zu machen, was er will. Jede Art
von Kunst, weil er gesetzlich
wurde diese Strafe gemacht und danach kann
-er eigentlich wieder ein Künstler werden.
-Du redest von der Rechtsstaatlichkeit. Und
da bin ich auf jeden Fall dafür, dass wenn es keine
eindeutigen Belege gibt, dass man
immer rechtsstaatliche Verfahren
abwartet. Aber jetzt angenommen, wir würden jetzt
wissen und mitbekommen irgendwo in der Garderobe
hat ein Kollege eine Kollegin
vergewaltigt, und da muss natürlich
erst mal ein Verfahren durchgehen, würde
ich trotzdem als Regisseur diesen Schauspieler
aus der Produktion nehmen,
ohne dieses rechtsstaatliche
Verfahren abzuwarten, weil es da bestimmte
Anhaltspunkte gäbe, dass das durchaus
passiert ist. Bei Darstellender Kunst,
bei Filmen, auch bei Musikproduktion
ist es schwieriger, als wenn ich vor einem
Gemälde stehe oder wenn ich ein Buch
schreibe, weil da gibt es nur eine Person
und das Werk. Aber bei Musikvideos,
bei Theater, bei Filmen, bei Serien, da gibt
es einfach eine ganz andere
Korrespondenz zwischen den Künsten und KünstlerInnen.
Das ist extrem schwer, da durch
eine Person quasi alles rauszunehmen.
Und das finde ich,
ist ein größeres Verbrechen.
Was ist, wenn der Typ, der einmal zwei
Sounds produziert hat von Michael Jackson,
was ist, wenn der zehnfacher Mörder
ist? Was machst du dann? Also du musst ja
eigentlich auch sagen, der hat
das Kunstwerk mit erschaffen, der war ja
-auch Teil im Grunde.
-Solange er durch seinen vielfachen Mord
das Kunstwerk nicht maßgeblich
mitgestaltet hat, also wenn sich sein Mord
nicht im Kunstwerk manifestiert,
würde ich sagen, dann ist es nicht relevant.
Ja, das meinte ich ja. Es wird
halt sehr, sehr komplex. Ist
es ein Michael-Jackson-Song? Oder ist
das der Song von dem ganzen Studio
und dem Typen der das Cover gemacht
hat? Oder die Frau. Und wer gehört alles dazu?
Und das ist mir ja gerade erst bewusst
geworden, durch was du gesagt hast. Es ist
-einfach riesig.
-Es gibt halt auch noch einen Aspekt, wie
man es unterscheiden kann. Und das ist
also jetzt in deinem Extrembeispiele
mit dem Produzenten, der dann
doch irgendwie zehnfacher Mörder ist.
Das könnte man sich ja vorstellen,
dass er zumindest die Morde begangen hat,
ohne in dieser Musikwelt unterwegs
zu sein, einfach weil er möglicherweise
einfach ein Mörder ist. Und es gibt
aber eben Verbrechen, die sehr spezifisch
mit der Kunstwelt oder mit der Musikwelt
zu tun haben und vielleicht sogar dadurch
begünstigt werden durch die hierarchischen
Verhältnisse, die da zumindest
in dieser Michael-Jackson-Zeit
vielleicht vorherrschten. Und dann würde
-ich da auch nochmal anders drüber reden.
-Ja, dem würde ich zustimmen.
-Anna, du wolltest was sagen?
-Ja, ich gebe dir auch absolut recht, dass
die Kunstwelt und die Theaterwelt und die Musikwelt
voller dieser Hierarchien sind,
die diese Dinge nun mal begünstigen.
Also dann müsste man entweder diese Hierarchien
ändern und was mir dabei auch klar
geworden ist als wir darüber gesprochen
haben, dass immer, wenn es um Machtmissbrauch
geht, um Hierarchien
in der Kunstwelt, geht es eigentlich
immer nur um Männer. Scheinbar gibt
es das nur so rum, wenn man
einfach Künstler verbannt aus der Kunstwelt,
-also Männer, dann: Problem gelöst.
-Das gibt es leider auch andersherum.
Autoritäre Frauen gibt es auch. Je mehr
Frauen in Machtpositionen kommen werden,
desto häufiger werden wir diese Fälle
haben. Vielleicht noch weniger, aber
ich glaube, diese Illusion, der können
wir uns jetzt nicht hingeben als Frauen,
-dass das nur ein Männerproblem ist.
-Was ich aber überzeugend finde, ist auf
jeden Fall eine Frage nach den Machtstrukturen
oder generell
der Strukturen. Ich glaube, wenn man
zum Beispiel bei uns im Theater schaut,
da gibt es eine sehr nach oben
gerichtete Hierarchie, die IntendantInnen
begünstigen, überhaupt Macht zu missbrauchen.
Und wenn du sagst, je mehr
Frauen in Positionen kommen, umso
mehr Machtmissbrauch kommt auch durch Frauen,
dann muss man auf jeden
Fall auch die Strukturen als solche
mit zur Verantwortung ziehen. Aber die Frage
ist auch, es geht immer um Zugänge.
Also wenn jemand wie Woody Allen
zum Beispiel eine Straftat begangen hat
und seit 60 Jahren mit sehr hoch
finanzierten Budgets Filme dreht und jetzt
trotzdem an der Mailänder Scala eine Oper
inszenieren kann und weiterhin mit Budgets
Filme drehen kann, stellt sich die Frage,
ob man unabhängig davon, ob man jetzt
sein vorheriges Werk canceln will
oder nicht, ob man so einer Person überhaupt
noch Zugang ermöglichen sollte
nach so einer Straftat. Und dann würde
ich auch eher sagen: Vielleicht
braucht man keine Filme mehr von Woody Allen,
nachdem er diese Straftat begangen
hat. Trotzdem würde ich Die Stadtneurotiker
1960 oder wann der gedreht wurde,
würde ich mir immer wieder anschauen und würde
immer wieder bewundern, was für ein toller
Film das ist. Aber ich würde
wahrscheinlich sagen, er sollte
heute eigentlich nicht mehr vollbudgetierte
-Filme drehen.
-Auf der gelben Seite sind alle einen
-Schritt auf dich zugegangen.
-Ich finde, es muss ja eigentlich um das,
was wir heute auch schon
angesprochen haben, gehen. Unter welchen Bedingungen
passiert das und was können wir in Zukunft
machen, dass das nicht mehr passiert?
Und dann geht es, glaube ich, mehr
darum und das klang ja auch schon an, also wer
bekommt jetzt eigentlich noch
Fläche? Weil die Fläche, die in jeglicher Kunst
zur Verfügung steht, ja immer auch begrenzt
ist. Und ich muss jetzt nicht
irgendwie, die Michael Jackson Alben
aus Spotify gelöscht haben. Aber ich würde
mich schon wundern, wenn der Rolling
Stone das jetzt noch fünf Mal irgendwie
als Cover führt. Und da würde ich mich
dann schon ein bisschen beschweren.
Also das muss trotzdem verfügbar
bleiben und kann ja kontextualisiert werden.
-Was und wie das passiert ist.
-Man merkt also zu diesem Punkt der
Diskussion, dass sehr viele Dinge
tatsächlich individuelle Entscheidungen
auch sind. Ihr habt euch gerade
noch einen Schritt auf Dax zubewegt. Warum?
-Ja weil es stimmt, was er sagt.
-Fläche.
Ja, genau das, genau das finde
ich, ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt,
wo ich auch sagen würde an der Stelle
macht es keinen Sinn, den Autor vom Werk
zu trennen, weil wir natürlich
demographisch und auch sonst sozial gucken
müssen: Wer bekommt überhaupt Raum und Aufmerksamkeit,
wer darf sich durchsetzen?
Weil natürlich ist das Werk zwar
theoretisch autonom, aber dass es über
Jahrhunderte von weißen Männern
gemacht wurde, kann kein Zufall sein, sondern ist
wiederum etwas, was wir aktiv
bearbeiten müssen. Und dann kommt die Verbindung
zwischen der Persönlichkeit dessen,
der es gemacht hat und dem Werk wieder rein.
Wenn man das jetzt mal weiter
spinnt, Balbina, sollten dann nur noch Menschen
Kunst machen, die straffrei sind,
die fehlerlos sind? Und wo kommen wir dann
-hin? Geht das überhaupt?
-Also ich glaube, es gibt niemanden, der
fehlerlos ist. Und die Definition
von straffrei ist für mich
auch eine schwierige, weil was ist
Strafe überhaupt? Ich glaube, was mir jetzt
auch klar geworden ist in den letzten
Minuten, dass uns an der Begrenzung
der Kunstfreiheit, glaube ich, am meisten
stört, wenn sie vom Staat aus betrieben
wird und wenn etwas auf den Index
kommt. Aber womit wir alle irgendwie mehr
oder weniger d'accord sind, ist,
dass ein Diskurs geführt werden kann. Also
auch ihr, die sagt, Kunstfreiheit
sollte nicht begrenzt werden und kann abgekoppelt
vom Künstler wahrgenommen werden. Auch ihr sagt
natürlich: Wenn es eine schwierige
Vita gibt oder wenn es Vorwürfe gibt
im Raum, die schwerwiegend sind, dann kann
der Diskurs eröffnet werden.
Und ich glaube, dass ist das Wichtige,
dass das nicht von oben runter
plumpst. Und das heißt, der und der und der darf
jetzt nicht mehr, sondern dass es möglich
ist, heutzutage einen Diskurs über
Individuen, die Kunst erschaffen, zu führen,
dass das okay ist, weil das war
-eine lange Zeit nicht okay.
-Was meint ihr denn? Sollten wir
KünstlerInnen, die sich strafbar
gemacht haben, die Bühne entziehen, also
zum Beispiel sie rausschneiden, aus dem Programm
nehmen, sie nicht mehr im Radio
spielen? Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Um mal bei diesem Diskurs zu bleiben:
Wie wir alle wissen, entsteht Kunst
auch häufig auf der Straße, sei es jetzt Rap,
sei es Streetart. Wie können wir denn
verhindern, dass genau dieser Diskurs hier
nur in einer akademischen, elitären
Bubble stattfindet und dass wir damit Menschen
ausschließen, die aufgrund ihrer
Sozialisierung eben nicht den Zugang dazu
hatten? Also ganz konkret: Wie kriegen
wir diesen Diskurs von Twitter auch auf eben
-jene Straße, wo Kunst häufig entsteht?
-Also ich finde, man muss es trotzdem
versuchen zu retten, zu erklären, was ist
Kunst und ein Künstler ist nicht gleich
sein Werk. Ein Schauspieler ist nicht
das, was er darstellt. Ein Sänger ist nicht
das, was er singt, sondern diese Differenz,
das ist, glaube ich, eher
das Schwierige, den Leuten zu erklären.
Weil ich glaube, intuitiv verwechseln
wahnsinnig viele Leute den Schauspieler
mit der Rolle, den Rapper mit dem,
-was er singt.
-Und zwar auch auf Twitter. Auch gerade auf
-Twitter.
-Aber das Gute an Twitter ist ja, dass
jeder Künstler oder auch jeder aus dem Publikum
sozusagen heutzutage sich dann
auch dazu äußern kann. Also jeder
Kunstschaffende kann ja auch sagen: Ne,
Moment, ihr habt mich falsch
verstanden, ich bin nicht homophob oder ich meinte
das nicht so. Aber wenn jemand das dann
immer wieder tut und immer wieder, so
wie Xavier Naidoo oder so was, immer
wieder die gleiche Scheisse wiederholt,
dann weiß auch irgendwann das Publikum
wiederum: Okay, ne du hattest deine 50
Twitterchancen, wenn du
sie alle verspielt hast.
In dem Fall von Xavier Naidoo ist ja
auch durch seine Äußerungen der letzten Jahre
was passiert. Ich habe früher sehr gerne,
ich muss mich jetzt outen, seine Musik
gehört. Als ich 15 war, vielleicht
sogar als ich noch 16, 17 Jahre alt war,
weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Aber das gebe
ich jetzt einfach mal zu. Aber nachdem,
was er so gesagt hat und ich sein Werk
noch mal betrachtet habe, hat sich
auch meine Wahrnehmung verändert. Und das ist
auch spannend, wie quasi die Äußerung
eines Künstlers das eigene Werk
plötzlich beeinflussen können, indem es eine andere
Sichtbarkeit macht für das, was er damals
eigentlich schon immer in dem Werk drin
hatte, was man damals
aber noch nicht gesehen hat.
Da würde ich aber gerne
widersprechen, weil ich finde, na klar, also
aus der Rückschau ist es ein bisschen
wie beim Fußball, wenn man das Ergebnis kennt,
lässt sich das gut erklären,
was da passiert ist. Ich glaube aber,
dass bei Xavier Naidoo beispielsweise
bei der Art von Musik, die er gemacht hat,
um mal konkret bei dem Beispiel zu bleiben,
dann sieht man auch: ah ja da,
da war schon was drin, der große
Freiheitsgedanke oder hier die große
Skepsis gegen die Regierung. Aber das hätte
natürlich auch in vier, fünf andere
Richtungen dann auch sich
entwickeln können und es ist nicht zwangsläufig,
dass er jetzt irgendwie
mal bei Querdenken gespielt wird.
Das ist doch eigentlich ein schönes
Beispiel, oder? Der Xavier sorgt dafür,
dass ihn Leute freiwillig nicht mehr
hören, da muss man gar nichts zensieren.
Man kann die da weiterhin auf der Bravo
Hits sitzen lassen – "Wenn ein Lied
meine Lippen verlässt", ist immer
noch ein schöner Song, aber man guckt sich
den Typen, man schaut ihn ganz anders
an als die meisten seiner Songs und das ist,
glaube ich, so ein Hoffnungszeichen,
dass die Leute das auch ganz gut zum Teil
-selber geregelt bekommen.
-Und Xavier Naidoo ist auch deswegen glaube
ich ein gutes Beispiel, weil er so
ein bisschen auch stellvertretend ist
für ein bisschen den Wandel,
vielleicht. So von Künstlern mit Social Media und so
weiter. Er kommt ja eigentlich aus einer Zeit,
wo über Bravo und so weiter
die Berichterstattung lief, man gar
nicht so viel selber Einfluss drauf hatte
und dann am Ende bespielt er sogar
mit dem eigenen Telegram-Kanal Zehntausende
und plötzlich ist er ganz unmittelbar
bei den Leuten, die ihm zuhören und das viel
ungefilterter. Da schaut kein Manager
mehr drüber, was er möglicherweise für neuen
Theorien hat. Und das ist irgendwie
auch bei ihm ganz spannend, weil ich glaube,
dass das halt für viele
KünstlerInnen, auch aus dem Bereich, den du gerade
meintest, Rap und so, das ist ja
auch so, dass viele es nicht anders kennen,
als dass sie ihr Leben über Instagram
und so weiter teilen. Und dadurch entsteht
aber glaube ich auch beim Publikum
oder bei uns eine andere Erwartungshaltung,
weil sie eben nicht irgendwie
abgehobene Figuren in so einem Olymps sind,
sondern sie sind sehr nah bei uns.
Und deswegen haben wir auch bestimmte
Erwartungen an sie, die wir auch an unser Umfeld
haben, weil sie so nah wirken.
Ich habe jetzt einen
Kompromissvorschlag für euch. Vielleicht überzeugt er euch
und ihr macht alle den Schritt
ins Kompromissfeld. Unsere Klicks
bei Streaminganbietern, unsere Kinokarten,
unsere Käufe im Buchladen und in Galerien,
die sind ein politisches Gut. Wenn wir problematische
KünstlerInnen finanzieren,
haben sie auch große Reichweiten
und niemand muss das unterstützen. Sind
wir uns einig, dass unser Konsumverhalten
große Auswirkungen auf bestehende
Strukturen hat und wir deshalb genau
reflektieren sollten, wem
wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit schenken?
Wenn ihr sagt: Ja, dann könnt ihr jetzt einen
Schritt auf mich zugehen. Alle sind so
einen kleinen Schritt auf mich zugegangen.
-Du hast am meisten gezögert Peter.
-Ja, weil ich stimme dem schon zu. Man
sollte sich das überlegen, will man
das? Aber ich mache es ja selber auch falsch.
Also ich hör mir die ganze Zeit
Morrissey an, der zum Teil privat relativ rechte
Thesen hat. Aber ich mag die Musik
so gerne, dass ich es auch selber nicht
durchziehe. Deswegen war ich so ein bisschen
am zögern, ob ich da wirklich
zustimmen sollte, weil ich es selber
falsch mache.
Außerdem muss man auch nicht
vergessen: Kunst ist nicht sauber und manchmal ist
auch Kunst total toll, gerade weil man
irgendwie weiß, der Typ, der das gemacht
hat, ist nicht komplett irgendwie
ethisch super, sondern das ist vielleicht
ein total versoffener Idiot. Und dann
finde ich es trotzdem interessant.
Oder wie bei Caravaggio, der war ein Mörder
und die Werke sind toll und man hat
irgendwie das Gefühl, da ist so
eine Überschreitung drin, so eine Kraft.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist auch das Kunstwerk
so gut, dass ich da jetzt nicht die ganze
Zeit drüber nachdenken möchte, hat
der seine Steuererklärung ordentlich
gemacht und ist er eigentlich immer brav?
-Das ist jetzt polemisch, aber –
-Absolut! Aber diese "Dirty Sexyness" gibt
es nur für Männer. Die ganzen, was weiß
ich, von Led Zeppelin bis keine Ahnung.
-Courtney Love!
-Okay, Courtney Love, die Einzige von den
allen. Dreckig, auf Drogen irgendwie.
Aber wenn du als Frau besoffen, wenn man mal
einmal, beim aus dem Auto steigen,
deinen Schlüppi siehst, bis du gleich
-eine schlechte Mutter.
-Ja, aber das müssen wir ändern!
Ich find das auch scheisse! Ich will
auch mal besoffen aus dem Auto steigen
-und dass man meinen Schlüppi sieht.
-Oder dieses Stigmatisieren von Winona
-Ryder, nachdem sie halt geklaut hat.
-Ja, genau! Geklaut.
Frauen sollten also dieselben
Privilegien haben oder das Privileg haben, dirty
zu sein. Da würde ich auf jeden
Fall zustimmen.
Ja, das Privileg zu haben,
sich krass daneben benehmen zu dürfen.
-Da können wir uns drauf einigen.
-Gut, wir können uns einigen auf: Frauen
dürfen auch Scheiße bauen
und wir finden sie immer noch gut.
Dann könnt ihr da eigentlich auch noch
mal einen kleinen Schritt zumindest
aufeinanderzugehen, wenn ihr euch
darauf einigen könnt. Und jetzt übergebe
ich an euch. Ihr könnt jetzt auf jedem
Feld noch mal die Köpfe zusammenstecken
und auch, wenn ihr schon halb im Kompromissfeld
seid, noch mal überlegen:
Was ist jetzt eigentlich euer konkreter
Kompromissvorschlag? Das kann
auch eine konkrete Forderung sein,
was auch immer, die ihr der anderen Seite
-gerne präsentieren wollt.
-Wir nehmen so lange Drogen, bis wir da
-reinfallen.
-Ich bin ein bisschen überfordert mit der
Runde, weil eigentlich sind wir,
glaube ich, alle sechs einer Meinung.
Bill Cosby ist jetzt wieder frei,
also der ist rechtlich freigesprochen.
Was meint ihr? Sollten wir KünstlerInnen,
die sich strafbar gemacht haben, die Bühne
entziehen? Und wo wäre da für euch die Grenze?
Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare.
Es geht halt
wirklich um die Verantwortung.
Würde man da sagen, dass man diese Szene
streichen sollte? Ich weiß nicht.
-Machst du schon. Ciao!
-Elke, du bist doch Kritikerin.
Also an die grüne Seite: Was habt ihr euch
überlegt? Was ist euer Kompromissvorschlag
-an das gelbe Feld?
-Unser Kompromissvorschlag ist: Wir bleiben
dabei, dass wir Künstler und Werk
trennen, aber wir finden es absolut sinnvoll,
wenn man sagt, man möchte einen
Künstler, eine Künstlerin nicht weiter unterstützen.
Man möchte sie nicht ökonomisch
stärken. Man möchte ihnen Sichtbarkeit entziehen,
-dass man das dann über diesen Weg macht.
-Was sagt ihr? Geht ihr einen Schritt auf
-die grüne Seite zu?
-Grundsätzlich positiv, weil das so der
Konsens ist, den wir alle sechs
schon einigermaßen hatten. Ja. Kann ich jetzt
-nichts dagegen sagen.
-Ich auch nicht.
Anna auch nicht? Okay, gut, dann könnt
ihr einen Schritt nach vorne gehen. Und jetzt
könnt ihr euren
Kompromissvorschlag vortragen an die grüne Seite.
Männer raus aus der Kunst? Nein, just
kidding. Wir haben uns überlegt, das ist
auch kein Kompromiss und ich glaube,
wir sind da auch wiederum alle einer Meinung,
dass wir generell eigentlich in sehr vielen
Punkten wahrscheinlich
einer Meinung sind. Wir haben
uns noch überlegt, dass wir als Kunst
und Kulturschaffende ja eine bestimmte
Verantwortung haben und wir haben ja
auch eine besondere Macht, die nämlich
darüber hinausgeht, als nur zu sagen:
Ich kaufe das Konzertticket nicht,
sondern wir können ja auch unsere Kollegen
sozusagen kritisch beäugen. Wir können
sagen: Mit dir trete ich nicht auf,
mit dir stelle ich nicht aus. Und diese Macht
sollten wir auch ausnutzen.
Und ergänzen würden wir das vielleicht
noch um folgenden Kompromiss Schrägstrich
Forderung. Also in dieser Diskussion
tauchen immer wieder Fragen auf,
die sehr auf den Einzelnen
abzielen. Hörst du noch den und den Künstler?
Oder wie gehst du damit um, dass du
mit Spotify und an der Kinokasse
den und den Künstler noch
supportest? Und ich finde es ein bisschen wohlfeil,
weil man blockiert sich selber
damit, dann an einen Punkt zu kommen, wo man
tatsächlich was ändern könnte.
Natürlich gibt es irgendwo eine Verantwortung beim
Einzelnen, aber das ist dann so
komplex und so schwierig, um da allgemein
was zu formulieren, dass es mir oder auch uns
wir gerade festgestellt haben,
eher darum geht: Wer hat denn
wirklich Macht, sozusagen in den einzelnen
Kunstbetrieben was zu verändern? Also
wer fördert zum Beispiel in der bildenden
Kunst oder in der Literatur, wer
stellt Festivals auf und so weiter. Ich glaube,
wenn diese Leute ans Umdenken
kommen, dann ist um einiges mehr geworden,
als wenn jetzt der Einzelne
aufhört, Michael Jackson zu hören.
-Ist das was, wo ihr zustimmen würdet?
-Ja, sehr, sehr gutes Argument.
Es gibt nun mal sehr viele
Künstler, die fragwürdig sind: Nolde, Wagner,
wie auch immer. Statt die vielleicht
alle sozusagen rauszunehmen aus der Kultur,
weil wir uns dann wiederum ja auch ins eigene
Fleisch schneiden würden, geht
es vielmehr um Kontext is King und auch darum,
wie man historisch Dinge irgendwie
-noch mal betrachtet.
-Ja, dem kann ich nichts hinzufügen. Aber
ich plädiere auch noch mal dafür,
was wir heute gelebt haben in dem Gespräch,
dass man dieses Thema
ausdifferenziert und dass man eben nicht pauschal
nach einer Antwort sucht, die auf diese Frage
zu finden ist, weil die wird man
nicht finden, die kann man mit einem
Satz auch nicht beantworten. Man muss
sie ausdifferenzieren. Man muss
die Kunstbereiche unterscheiden. Man muss
eine Straftat von anderen
Vergehen unterscheiden. Man kann das nicht
beantworten. Vielleicht muss man sich
von dem Versuch verabschieden, diese Frage
-klar beantworten zu wollen.
-Ich würde sagen, dass ich das lange nicht
mehr gesehen habe, dass so viele
Leute im Kompromissfeld sind. Ich danke euch
für die Diskussion. Ich finde,
die Diskussion hat sehr gut gezeigt,
wie unfassbar komplex dieses Thema
ist. Einmal muss man erst mal darüber
diskutieren, was überhaupt Kunst ist,
wo die anfängt, wo die aufhört. Dann muss man
darüber sprechen, wo sind die Grenzen?
Das ist natürlich auch sehr individuell,
ab wann wird eine Grenze
überschritten? Und dann als drittes natürlich: wer
entscheidet darüber? Die Gesellschaft?
Die Justiz? Also da gibt es noch sehr viel
weitere Diskussionen, die wir zu diesem Thema
führen können. Falls
ihr auch bei der nächsten Diskussion
dabei sein wollt, dann lasst doch gerne ein Abo
für diesen Kanal da. Hier oben findet
ihr ein weiteres Video von 13 Fragen und hier
unten ein weiteres Video zum Thema.